IT’S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE"."
THE PRESIDENT MAKING AN
ANNOUNCEMENT MOMENTS AGO AT A
WHITE HOUSE EVENT SAYING THAT HE
HAS BEEN TAKING
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE FOR ABOUT A
WEEK AND A HALF NOW.
>> THE FRONT LINE WORKERS, MANY,
MANY ARE TAKING IT.
I HAPPEN TO BE TAKING IT.
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
>> Reporter: TO THE
WHITE HOUSE DOCTOR RECOMMEND YOU
TAKE IT?
SPEAK WITH A WHITE HOUSE DOCTOR
DID RECOMMEND GRADY SAID WOULD
YOU LIKE IT?
I’D LIKE TO TAKE IT.
I WOULD LIKE THE PEOPLE OF THIS
NATION TO FEEL GOOD.
I DON’T WANT THEM BEING SICK AND
THERE’S A VERY GOOD CHANCE THIS
HAS AN IMPACT SO I’M TAKING IT.
THE ZINC AND THE HYDROXY.
ALL I CAN TELL YOU IS SOPHIA I
SEEM TO BE OKAY.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT ADDING
THAT HE’S HAD NO SYMPTOMS FOR
CORONAVIRUS AND IS TAKING THE
DRUG FOR PRECAUTIONARY MEASURES.
NEWS BREAKING RECENTLY.
GREG, LET ME GO TO YOU BECAUSE
YOU COVER THIS.
YOU’VE TALKED ABOUT THIS DRUG
FOR MANY WEEKS.
WE ALL READ ABOUT IT.
HOPES AND CONTROVERSIES ABOUT IT
AND NOW THE PRESIDENT DROPPING
THE SNOOZE INTO THE NEWS CYCLE
AT ABOUT 4:30 THIS AFTERNOON.
>> Greg: I LOVE IT WHEN HE
SAYS VERY CASUALLY, YEAH, I’M
TAKING IT.
I WOULD’VE TOLD YOU SOONER BUT
YOU DIDN’T ASK.
THE MOST TRANSPARENT PRESIDENT
EVER.
IT’S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT HIS
EXPLANATION WAS EQUITABLY
NUANCED.
IT IS ABOUT WHO YOU GIVE IT TO
AND WHEN.
HE IS CORRECT, THERE ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE TAKING IT WHO KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
I’VE TALKED TO DOCTORS, MANY
PEOPLE YOU KNOW WHEN THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT AS A PROPHYLACTIC
TWO MONTHS AGO.
HE WAS DEAD ON ABOUT THE LAST
STUDY WHICH THE MEDIA GLOMMED
ONTO BECAUSE THEY WANTED THE
DRUG TO BE A FAILURE BECAUSE
THEY WANTED THAT DRUG TO FAIL SO
THEY CITED A STUDY IN WHICH THE
DRUG WAS GIVEN TO PEOPLE
ESSENTIALLY NEAR DEATH.
YOU COULDN’T TELL WHAT WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN, IF IT WAS TOO LATE.
WHEN YOU GET THIS DRUG, THE
PEOPLE WHO COULDN’T TOLERATE IT,
YOU CAN’T HAVE ANY KIND OF HEART
CONDITION OR ARRHYTHMIAS.
YOU CAN TAKE IT PROPHYLACTICALLY
AND ITS FDA APPROVED, IT’S BEEN
AROUND FOR DECADES.
IT’S ONE OF THOSE THINGS, IF
IT’S AVAILABLE TO YOU AND YOU
CAN TAKE IT, YOU CAN DO IT.
THAT’S A PRUDENT WAY OF LOOKING
AT IT.
>> Dana: DAGEN, THERE WAS AN
FDA WARNING ABOUT GREG WAS
TALKING ABOUT, IF YOU HAVE ANY
SORT OF HEART CONDITION, YOU
SHOULDN’T TAKE IT.
I DON’T HAVE A FDA DOCUMENT
FRONT OF ME BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE CONDITIONS LIKE LUPUS
THAT TAKE THIS DRUG BECAUSE IT
DOES HELP THEM, IT’S PROVEN TO
HELP THEM.
AND THEY NEED THE DRUG.
A RUN ON THIS DRUG BY PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRYING TO PREVENT GETTING
CORONAVIRUS WHEN WE KNOW THAT
ACTUALLY WASHING YOUR HANDS AND
NOT TOUCHING YOUR FACE IS
PROBABLY THE BEST WAY, THERE IS
ARE CONCERNED BY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LUPUS THAT IF THERE IS A RUN ON
THIS DRUG, DOCTORS ARE BEING
PRESSURED TO PRESCRIBE IT TO
PEOPLE WHO DON’T NECESSARILY
NEED IT YET -- I’M NOT SAYING
PEOPLE SHOULDN’T TAKE IT.
I’M NOT SAYING THAT IT ALL BUT
THERE IS A CONCERN BY THOSE WHO
ARE ACTUALLY SICK.
>> Dagen: RIGHT.
IF YOU’RE NOT SICK AND YOUR
DOCTOR TELLS YOU KNOW, DON’T
TAKE IT, PLEASE LISTEN TO YOUR
DOCTOR.
LEAVITT TOOK PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
DO A GIANT CANNONBALL INTO THE
NEWS CYCLE.
WE GOT THIS INCREDIBLE NEWS ON
THE VACCINE FROM MODERNA THAT
THEY ANNOUNCED EARLY THIS
MORNING.
THAT’S WHY THE MARKET WAS UP SO
MUCH.
THE IMMUNE RESPONSE, SOME OF THE
HEALTHY VOLUNTEERS WHO ARE
VACCINATED IN THE CLINICAL
STUDY, IT WAS INDUCED.
THEY HAD A HEALTHY RESPONSE TO
IT.
THIS IS ONE OF THE FIRST
VACCINES THAT WE ARE GOING TO
HEAR ABOUT.
MODERNA AND PFIZER ARE WORKING
ON VACCINES, JOHNSON & JOHNSON
JUST TO NAME A FEW.
THIS IS WHAT WOULD HAVE
DOMINATED THE NEW CYCLE.
IN TERMS OF HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE,
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
OBSERVATIONAL STUDIES ABOUT IT
ON THERE WAS ONE THAT WAS DONE
IN NEW YORK CITY NOT LONG AGO, A
FEW WEEKS AGO.
IT BASICALLY FOUND NO IMPACT
FROM THE DRUG, I’LL FIND IT.
THERE WAS NO IMPACT ON PEOPLE
WHO WERE SICK, NOT POSITIVE AND
NOT NEGATIVE.
WE ARE WAITING FOR LONGER-TERM
TRIALS TO COME OUT.
>> Dana: THE NEWS ABOUT THE
MODERNA VACCINE BROKE BEFORE THE
MARKETS OPEN TODAY, JUAN, AND IT
WAS ONE OF THEM REASONS, I DON’T
KNOW WHERE IT FINISHED BUT IT
WAS ABOUT A THOUSAND POINT UP,
THE MARKET.
GOOD NEWS ON THAT VACCINE THAT
COULD POSSIBLY BE AVAILABLE FOR
EMERGENCY USE BY FALL, IF
EVERYTHING GOES WELL, TO CAVEAT
THAT.
THIS DEBATE ABOUT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE SOMEHOW
BECAME A RED VERSUS BLUE ISSUE.
I CAN’T IMAGINE THIS IS NOT
GOING TO STIR THAT UP AGAIN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Juan: I DON’T KNOW ABOUT
RED VERSUS BLUE, BUT I THINK
IT’S A TRUMP ISSUE.
IT’S ALL ABOUT HIM.
WHAT’S INTERESTING TO ME IN THIS
BREAKING NEWS IS I GUESS HE’S
WORRIED ABOUT GETTING SICK AND
MORE SO THAN I MIGHT HAVE
APPRECIATED, IF HE HAS BEEN
TAKING THIS FOR A WEEK AND A
HALF.
THAT WOULD EVEN BE BEFORE THERE
WAS CONCERN ABOUT
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE AND THEN
THERE WAS ONE OF HIS AIDES AND
OF COURSE THE VICE PRESIDENT’S
PRESS SECRETARY.
WHO TESTED POSITIVE.
THE VICE PRESIDENT SELF ISOLATED
BECAUSE OF HIS ASSOCIATION WITH
HIS PRESS SECRETARY.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
WORRIED, AND WE KNOW AS JESSE
LIKES TO REMIND ME, THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS A GERMAPHOBE, BUT
HE DIDN’T WEAR THE MASK.
I DON’T KNOW ABOUT HAND WASHING.
SOMEBODY TOLD ME THE OTHER DAY
THAT EVEN NOW THE WHITE HOUSE
MESS IS CLOSED.
I THINK DANA, YOU WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT’S PRETTY SEVERE
FOR PEOPLE WHO WORK AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
YOU HAVE TO TO DO TAKEOUT.
I THINK THERE’S A SENSE WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT THINGS ARE
MAYBE MORE SEVERE THAN THE
PRESIDENT LIKES TO TELL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN TERMS OF
WORRYING ABOUT THIS PANDEMIC.
TO PICK UP ON WHAT DAGEN WAS
TALKING ABOUT, THERE’S GOOD NEWS
ABOUT THE VACCINE BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT THE BIG HOSPITAL STUDIES
ABOUT THE USE OF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IN
NEW YORK CITY, IF YOU LOOK AT
THE VA STUDY, ACADEMIC STUDIES,
EVERYONE SAYS THERE’S NO
EVIDENCE THIS IS GOING TO HAVE
AN IMPACT, POSITIVE IMPACT, THAT
IT HAS REAL EFFICACY IN TERMS OF
PREVENTING YOU FROM GETTING THE
DISEASE BUT APPARENTLY THE
PRESIDENT BELIEVES HIS OWN SPIN.
YOU’RE NOT GETTING IT FROM ANY
GOVERNMENT OR ACADEMIC AUTHORITY
AUTHORITY.
>> Dana: I’M NOT SAYING
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE IS EVERYTHING
BUT ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE DOES
EXIST WHERE SOME PEOPLE SAY IF
THEY WEREN’T SEVERELY SICK AND
THEY TOOK IT, IT DID HELP THEM
GET BACK.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS THAT HE ASKED
THE DOCTOR AND THE DOCTOR SAID
OKAY, WE CAN TRY IT, YOU’RE OKAY
TO TRY IT.
WE DO KNOW ONE THING, THE
WHITE HOUSE MEDICAL DOCTORS ARE
RESPONSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS IN THE BEST
HEALTH POSSIBLE BECAUSE HE’S THE
LEADER OF THE FREE WORLD AND THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
BEFORE EVERYBODY RUNS AWAY WITH
THIS, I GUESS -- I DO THINK THE
DOCTOR SAYING WE CAN DO IT, WE
SHOULD HAVE SOME CONFIDENCE IN
THEM.
>> Jesse: JUAN IS ACTING LIKE
THE PRESIDENT JUST ANNOUNCED HE
WAS MAKING METH IN THE EAST WING
WING.
THIS IS NOT SOME RADICAL
COCKTAIL.
THE PRESIDENT BEING LIKE I’LL
TAKE SOME UPPERS, SOME DOWNERS,
MAY BE A SHOT OR TWO.
JUAN, THE DOCTOR OF THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESCRIBE THIS.
IT’S UNDER THE ADMINISTRATION --
GO >> Juan: WAIT, WAIT.
HE SAID HE COULD DO IT.
>> Jesse: HE ADMINISTERED IT.
WHAT’S THE DIFFERENCE.
HE DIDN’T GO TO CVS TO GET IT?
YOU ARE SPLITTING HAIRS.
IF THE PRESIDENT ASKS THE DOCTOR
AND THE DOCTOR SAYS HE ASKED,
THAN WHAT’S WRONG WITH THAT.
EVERYBODY’S ACTING LIKE YOU
SHOULD’VE SEEN THE MEDIA WHEN HE
MADE THE ANNOUNCEMENT, IT WAS
LIKE WHEN YOUR DAUGHTER COMES
HOME FROM COLLEGE AND I DINNER,
SHE’S LIKE YEAH, I’M PREGNANT.
AND IT’S LIKE THE PARENTS ARE
LIKE WHOA, WHAT?
YOU HAVE BEEN HOME FOR A WEEK
AND NOW YOU TELL ME?
COME ON.
ANTIMALARIAL DRUG THAT PEOPLE
TAKE ALL OVER THE WORLD, IT’S
BEEN TAKEN FOR 40 TO 60 YEARS.
IT WORKS FOR SOME AND DOESN’T
WORK FOR OTHERS.
I THINK WE ARE MAKING A LITTLE
BIT TOO BIG OF A DEAL OUT OF
THIS, LIKE WE ALWAYS DO WHEN IT